One of the cool things about superheroes
is that they rarely win battles
based on their superpowers alone and the
most common denominator that you see in
the movies that i think is often
overlooked is the usage of science and
engineering and technology and the story
behind the Captain America shield
according to the comics is that during
fighting of the Panzer Division tanks in
WW2, FDR tasked army scientist
named Myron MacLain for making a new steel
to make their tanks out of and he was
trying to make a tank hatch in a cast
shape and while he was doing the
experiment a mystery element fell in and
that mystery element ended up solidifying the material into what would later
become the shield. Captain America's
shield is an amazing piece of the comic book universe.
It's one of the most
indestructible things and as an engineer
and as a scientist I seek to design
materials that can live in these
extremes especially with
transportation applications. If we can
get lighter and stronger then we get
more fuel-efficient.  There's been a major
example and that is the Ford F 150 which
is the most popular truck in North America.
Last year's Ford Model shifted
from using a steel frame to an aluminum frame.
Which saves a lot of mileage and
increases the fuel economy of the
vehicle by taking over 700lbs out of
the frame of the vehicle and as we
continue to do this our vehicles will
become more and more efficient.
Myron MacLain gave up too easy
he was never able to duplicate the
shield and its microstructure and
for a material scientists or a researcher
to say "I found something cool I'm not
able to do it again" is not a thing
that anyone should be saying now.  As a
scientist we can look at individual
atoms of a material.  We have
computational codes that let us predict
things that we're not able to see.  I feel like
as a scientist I'm able to tackle
problems that society can't tackle alone.
I feel that it's really really interesting
to get into science and see science in
the movies and I hope that people out
there could recognize that there's a lot
of opportunities to do those same kind
of things the superheroes do.
Hey! Do you want even more Fig. 1?
check out our previous episode here and
don't forget to subscribe!